yeah what's doing I think I want to try
to do a podcast or what what's that well
I talk about what I do during the day
and maybe conversations of course I
never heard that term so what do you put
it on the Internet yeah yeah so bad I
don't have it I never heard that term
before
what is the name again the podcast pot
chaos
PLT Tod CAS T all right I never heard
that term this is the mild Adventures of
Fred Stoller with amber Tozer next to me
and we have a great special guest
oh I don't had a fade but um we're
trying to do it do a new thing Felipe it
wasn't that good fade where amber and I
was last week it was just amber you know
people wanted to hear who she was and I
didn't really know her so well and I
never talked I'm super cool I'm like the
super quiet sidekick
but she's so funny and people were
saying a funny she is so I wanted to
test it and I'm just kidding no she is
funny you know what she's the best at
when you send her funny well a text or
something and she comments like yeah
they are crazy well no it's funnier than
that she's really and she does it right
away so how do we utilize that but but
no no she's a fun chemistry why are you
talking about me like I'm not here even
though you're saying really nice things
saying it to believe it I know Kirchen
right now this is your life this is
called my opening segment with amber
where I talk to someone else about amber
so
my ethnic segment she talked about her
now so so basically we had a whole
session with Amber and I brought in a
guy I feel like so hacky and old school
because he was good because you could
abuse him and I'm not usually a bully
but he was so crazy but I really
shouldn't need that because you can tell
him to shut up which people should tell
me
so amber Tozer we talked last week and
you'd be proud of me because I only beat
myself up a little bit about some things
you said about me what how you interrupt
people yes because I believe that adage
you hatin someone what you see in
yourself you spot it you got it
cotton there's a few friends they talk
over me on the phone and I'm going like
this with a phone you know they
interrupt and oh man I'm so I hate I'm
so hating myself but not too much
because you know you're doing it already
interrupt and then you keep interrupting
okay I'm self aware of honey because
then you end up like going on this
hilarious like a rabbit hole in your
mind but I don't I don't like when
people talk over me I flinch so so I'm
gonna ask you a favor since she's like
them I have this Bell and every time I
you throw up ring the bell
Bing so that's what your job is when I'm
being annoying ring the bell
see I just bought this prop so much I
can't use the r-word anymore today yeah
oh I see that's a thing that's why it's
bad cuz I already want to ask him
questions in the Latino community did
have like [ __ ] what's the thing that
you call people there watch asados
they're [ __ ] but it also makes
special need special needs very nice
kind of ways I know that that's all that
means [ __ ] or mean stupid and crazy
what is no medically correct way to say
special needs I don't know man
mama always to the bad ones yeah so
owned or don't though I do you yeah I
with this MN so
let's do better is that what I [ __ ]
so amber so we want to try to do a thing
catching up on the week and and so
basically I had my first dream with you
in it
oh boy oh yeah you told me you were
gonna tell me this is funny close top of
that Bell and it's kind of funny cuz I
said let's save these for the podcast
and if they suck then it's more like
what the hell what all right no no no so
no this is a legit dream so basically
this is how our I am I see this I
thought it's at $59 ago man I would have
got it but it's $59 and it's $5.99 so
world market you thought it was $60 yeah
you never know this could have been a
gold you know antique thing that's great
I don't know alright tell your dream we
have a great guest that we have to ask
okay so so to backtrack it amber was
away for six weeks
and this is important in the dream and
while she was gone for the bulk of the
dream I I had a bad um but so-called
virus very weak and a heat wave so she
came to visit me but I was living with
my parents don't even though my father's
dead but it wasn't the house in Brooklyn
it looked different was lil Messier so I
kind of was slumped against the wall in
the heat way still not feeling good with
my shirt off and she sees me and I go
it's okay you might have my shirt of you
already knew I was skinny right yeah
yeah so I was apologizing for being
skinny like taking the liberty that you
show up you know and I've my shirt off
but I felt it was okay what do you think
this dream oh maybe it just means that
you're interrupt but and I stopped
myself I pause a lot so as I'm easy to
interrupt because I sort of I see say
nine sentences before you're in my mind
before I say the one that I want to say
that's why she's good on Twitter maybe
maybe it means that you know that I
don't judge you
yeah I think I'm think I was ov
honorable with you and I think I was
afraid at first cuz she you know I
thought you
Twitter character that goes hey gimme
hot guys ooh Lance Armstrong no I know
you don't
okay woman when every guy tells a joke
of mine the the worst that's funny I
should know she's great on Twitter she's
got 50,000 followers she's had as a book
deal cuz of actuator in so she she's
okay but Phillippi didn't listen that's
why he's late he was listening no he was
doing his research so I think yes you
are really cool and I think I'm not
scared to be vulnerable and I think it's
also I complimented her once and she she
said you know whenever hey didn't get
the idea Fred
so I think I was trying to say also in
the dream I have my shirt off but I'm
not being creepy maybe I was afraid as
being prejudge amount yeah your parents
house yeah so as creepy yeah I think
meaning if she was around when I had the
virus she would have been understand I
don't know okay so basically and then we
we met at farmers market and I had
something else I want any the heatwave
this is how lucky I am
do you live here do you live in LA yeah
I'm Pomona oh wait one less story hello
if you do that it's it's funny how I
alright this is what I should learn
about podcasting do you notice for you
think you have a good story prepared and
it's never good and the best stuff is
when you're having a conversation yeah
just tell it alright okay so what
happened so I I don't trust my feelings
I was at the heatwave at farmer's market
hot to the laundry right man hey how's
your cat bill well I have to give her
fluids for her campaign so it's already
not good so basically um in the morning
I still need a hot coffee to do my stuff
I don't muck yeah I do mean that way
okay that could be weird I'm so scared
she's okay
gross horizon judges so basically and
she's so cool and I'm learning who
really am
I do judge you but I don't judge you I
don't have you so meanly as I think well
maybe you do you know I don't okay no no
all right I'm so basically this is how
lucky I am truck is a better word I
wanted to get hot coffee but I feel you
can't so he's walked up to the Coffee
corner and I was hoping to see pee other
people drinking hot coffee so I could do
it like it was just iced coffee on line
I went to done it so his look oh he got
it is that pathetic I know you probably
think you're mad people gonna be staring
whether they are weirdos drinking a hot
ass car and it's hot as day it's how you
serious but here's the thing was a bad
idea I know I I'm so nervous which makes
no sense that the woman going hot really
Fred when I wanted it and if you put it
with a Frappuccino the machine would
have probably been done forever to go
for proper cheeto and they'd go sorry no
more ice cream rod yes I'm not having
good banter about the week anything with
you amber someone got shot the Comedy
Store
she what all right this chemistry or you
have chemistry you gonna keep talking
you gotta keep talking about your story
I give up to I bail too easily what I
learned is I can't I can't free right
what the banter is gonna be this is the
thing with you you have like this plan
in your head I know more this
conversation which you have no control
over the conversation and I wanted her I
want her to go you [ __ ] I'm not gonna
ring the bell that's more annoying than
interrupting that plan
I want to ring it
all right all right when the segment's
over that's women okay why do you feel
toggle we're people though I don't I
think it's a little a few things it's
you want to get to the end huh
I think minor anxiety I think it's that
I'm very shy in life women people I'm
either on a date and I know this isn't a
date but it seems like one either I'm
totally withdrawn with my head down and
I want to leave or I'm like let me tell
you back there so I want to get this in
oh you brought thing up and I got a
relax go Fred they have something to say
all right you know II mean I guess I'm
its that trying to score and it's you
just want to be heard yes that's so
wrong no but I hate it is when you're
trying to talk I know a guy he's a comic
and I feel like when I talk to him he
just keep talking and talking and
talking and I can't find the leeway
there's no weight for a punch line you
can laugh go ha the point of the story
yes like the guy keeps talking to
talking and then you feel like where do
I put my two cents in and they never ask
your new question never I had an anxiety
attack I was almost that one I know I
had an anxiety attack I was you know
when I wanted to leave a party
I wanted to leave a party and it was a
birthday party and the woman was opening
her gifts so you had to sit there for
every unwrapping there's no way you
could do the polite I got a leave in the
middle of opening gifts
you know can you go to the bathroom
should give you a present for open mind
bye I uh all right this is not gonna
work because I want to try is a
one-minute segment okay Felipe where
it's called pearls of wisdom because my
mother's name is pearl and I thought if
people like that opening and some said
they want to hear more of her I had some
audio of different this is a
conversation I'm about to go to Fred
will it's party okay
okay and then I introduce Felipe no no
all right number all right number
segments
can I try another segment all right all
right I got a fine then we have another
segment to he it's whenever he calls in
I'll text a who speed weed you know he
was supposed to
be here okay this is my mother this is
the way this is it Christmas party just
to spend a lot of million things but not
really he's so sick but how'd you get to
so friendly with him
bye bye Jewish your friend said Willard
yeah no uh-huh okay I don't what I'm
really all right I'll shut this I'll
shut this all right hang on at the guy
Ryder I can't help you mom
all right parties this year next year I
was a year or two ago now Felipe Esparza
all right we'll work on that ambra what
do you think Mike if you're gonna do
that we need to be able to like talk
about it after you can't be like crazy
phone call and then be like alright yeah
this should be our banter on the phone
call you yeah stop it once in a while
and yeah yeah and like sort of break it
down but I do think we should focus on
our guests right now okay because we can
revisit the phone call with the guests
yeah but first I think we should make it
about the guests Felipe Esparza was so
cool he's got is what's a full podcast
here he's got a web series the the shop
the winner of Last Comic Standing season
7 big on the road I've opened for him
he's the reason I'm doing this podcast
cuz I went to your wedding yes and and I
gotta tell you something about this is a
great guy Lambert oh when did you get
married
um December 12 No December 13 2014 12 13
14 yeah and I gotta tell you this what a
mensch this guy is is that I I didn't
deal with the magnet right away did you
send the magnet save the day to
something yes I I didn't deal with it
you know weddings it's so so then all of
a sudden like oh I never RSVP'd and I
see on your face booking somebody's
where a Chris was in town for the
wedding and I said out Felipe I'm so
sorry I didn't RSVP you come on down man
it don't matter and then I was driving
right there and with Felipe I said you
know you I didn't have the anxiety I had
to come with a gift because you're such
a a lot of guys will say come on man
don't worry about running and getting a
gift and they don't really mean it with
you am I correct
you're such a great guy it didn't matter
I didn't bring a gift no didn't matter
we don't want no gifts he's such a great
guy so I met al magical runs the studio
and he knew me from Marc Maron and that
led to this meeting him at your wedding
and it was funny because he's a vegan
amber and so there were I didn't know so
I said could I have that
and they go you a vegan no go you can't
remember that it was a vegan security
guard they're making sure that vegans
aid vegan food and regular people ate
the regular food how long have you been
a vegan so 2010
well 2011 I think that yeah
did you see Fred and Vinnie yes I love
Fred and Vinnie because I don't mean if
I knew you other than know your report
saw it because Vinnie D'Angelo said I'm
the fattest vegetarian but that's
different than vegans yes because he's
cheese can did you do it for health
reasons or did you yes I will for health
reasons I was a fat of course and I'm
always trying to Atkins diet at first
yeah and it didn't work mom I guess I
got I'm constipated for like six days on
the Atkins diet because I never get
water weight denied that says don't
drink water nobody I never drank water
cuz I drank so it all the time I never
drink water like if I got through judge
Angus order or die cold have you ever
seen fat sick and nearly dead that many
watch it
I saw forks over knives that will maybe
turn B oh yeah yeah that's a good one I
I wish I could because I love animals
but releases sort of dopamine in your
brain and so you can be addicted to it
so sometimes when you eat cheese and you
feel really good it's almost like a drug
there's this new study coming out that
it releases like the good feeling
chemical in your brain amber what I
start now let me tell you about him two
things I started opening for him he I
know
alright this is gonna sound racist and
whenever you say that it's very rare I
never start a sentence like that but
he's Mexican but he doesn't do the thing
where the homies you talk about being
mexicana but you are obviously Mexican
but you don't really overdo it where we
you know you're so severely catering
his influences were guys like Steven
right quirky non sequitur one-liners yes
Steven right Giordano Steve it right
Rodney Dangerfield
Fred star first older
mitch hedberg one in iran - so you
started you were very low-key yes and
then you learn like I do who's
interrupts a lot that you can't yes I
was deadpan and he learned you don't
headline and make money when you're
deadpan I did I did
so now what are you what do you like now
yo man where's my prisoner homies now
those guys are still working the same
rooms when I started those type of
Latino community now I didn't know this
circuit but I when I kind of went back
to stand up momentarily I went to Liam's
eye I put on Facebook I'm doing it so
these people reach out they go you want
to do my room they go tell me 20 minutes
away and I'm going past Clair mount and
it was this room and I didn't notice all
these Latino and black guys that it's
not even I don't want they do this
screaming and y'all man who's been in
prison yeah you call it that niche
what's it called MSNBC lockup stand up
embassy lumber every seein Missy Missy
life yeah and MSNBC lockup stand up yeah
but he's George Perez you know you're
like Louie Anderson had a good joke I
loved where he didn't know if he should
start with being fat he goes if I yeah
open with a joke about being fat they go
oh he's another guy talking about being
fat but if he doesn't he's afraid to go
you think he knows you got a kid but you
you are Mexican but again it's you have
to be you have to talk about it but you
don't do it in a way like that's who I
am
I know oh did you talk about it a lot or
do you just sort of I just thought about
it a lot yeah but it's not like even in
Pittsburgh it works I just I don't know
I just don't know it just was real you
know he's real he's so good that I
laughed at your stuff even if I don't
relate to it about having a stepson Oh
Kyle Joe where I said that to be a
horrible person nice to sell marijuana
to my son's mom new husband then I'm
gonna take his money and give it to her
as child support but something that's a
little bit sweet that was my 420 pyramus
key
but what about the steps on how they're
easier or at the mall no you're cheating
on your son what's the joke - that was a
most F son you know my son he's white he
has blond hair blue eyes everything I
wanted in a son so every time you my
stepson we walked together holding hands
you know you have blond hair blue eyes
yeah sometimes I see my real storm
coming and I feel like I'm cheating on
him
so I'm gonna let go my my son's my
stepson hand let go my hand freaky ha ha
give him your jacket
then my son gets upset because this is
my stepson and I'm gonna take out my
cord paper and I say listen your days
are Saturday from 9 to 9 right now
you're trespassing his wife my wife your
wife told me something that when use
wipes great I was wishing you would come
she manages you does the merch and
everything but I opened for Felipe you
you kind of have to like stand with the
merch table come on man where were you
Fred
so either you got they're asking for you
so whenever you say they were asking for
me they're all ignoring me and but you
know but you remember there was a guy I
opened for you I forgot where no in a
temple Arizona and there's one guy we're
Seinfeld man say loud you know the girl
was kidnapped you huh he was he was
scary as [ __ ] and he grabs ready goes
come on take a side road he's our pal he
went in the green room looking face [ __ ]
it's I failed so then I knew it just
when I started doing stand-up again with
you was when I discovered weed and and
so we so some guy you set it up did
something called vape sword apes with
ABS and it's like crack it's what is
crack pipe and it's I didn't understand
it and it's weird and it was it was like
doing cords like taking 20 edibles and
I'm blitzed out of my mind
and the guy glass I felt man so then I
had paranoia when I got into my hotel
because I put him on Instagram or
something oh man we [ __ ] killed
we have guns in Arizona Seinfeld [ __ ]
you and he's funny so I took it off
Instagram because I was scared on
Facebook that he could you [ __ ] put
me on you know so that was the paranoia
I thought I was gonna get mad too but he
wasn't that mad Oh remember that woman
we took a photo with the one with the
boobs yes when I actually died of cancer
already yeah what happened was it the
first had a good time though but the
first time I opened for him some woman
is on line she goes could you touch my
boobs man touch my boobs to me and him
and his wife's there and I would go why
come on I have cancer I've cancer soin
all right and I thought oh she's gonna
lose them soon so do you know ground
with them and and it wasn't fun it was
it was she was you know you there's
other women I wish would say that I
don't mean the notion for that one
Hathaway so so then I go to said you
know breasts cos no colon cancer so
Stage four so no no no meaning she
didn't want okay man that a joke I
thought she was losing them like they
play with my breasts I'm gonna lose him
but it was cold cancer you know doc
camping lame you don't put the finger
part no cough see I try to I try to be
more ballsy with Amber cuz she's old
funny I thought that was funny
well it was the tip now you're I am
Marcin drizzle text me he goes hey
remember that woman that um French
daughter grabbed her boobs at the
flappers oh yeah man she passed away
from cancer okay almost had a great time
that night I could see now women lying
saying they have cancer my question is
what she wanting to be felt up because
she had cancer or she done that she was
trying to be half crazy funny and as I
say God bless her because she had such a
great attitude she said Stage four and
she was having a good time and you know
it's you know I they said did one for
the team Fred - one for the team you
know but no no again it really when you
when you work with Felipe the people
you know it's just so sweet how yeah you
got the greatest fans you know and stuff
it's up but okay but his what he lied to
his wife when he met her this is what
I'm trying to get to wait how did you
meet your wife or where'd you meet her
at the Laugh Factory well she was
training to work there oh I thought she
didn't she also work at UM
ice house yes would buys those so oh I
get it they trained at the Laugh Factory
to work at the ice another trade I laugh
at you to worry about laughs after him
proud to work at the Taj Mahal do you
remember do you remember the lie you
told your wife you know so many I don't
know she said that you lied you said you
only your two kids when you're three you
don't want to seem too weird because you
have three kids
oh yeah that's right I've had three kids
I don't know why I guess three is a lot
hi Mary three's a lot raised too much I
thought I have two from different women
do you have three from three different
ones we'll have three kids on two
different women yeah she thought with
Paul Rodriguez the son don't you saw me
she what she thought was Paul Rodriguez
like hang on Paul Rodriguez and that's
it okay orderly did you like her right
away right away man she's really cool
she she this guy he has people open for
him and he says they're so generous that
they have a certain amount they give and
the clubs are pathetic but they oh they
overcompensate you know I'm saying for
what the clubs don't give the people the
comics because some clubs don't pay the
opener the host doesn't get no money for
the whole week and the sometimes a
feature only gets like $200 for five
shows for the whole week so we've had
compensate and give them an extra three
hundred to make up for $100 a show so it
could be fair for everybody
no it's not that you know like the
comedian that took me on a road they
always paid me right like every glass
Russell Peters Paul Rodriguez giorno Pez
they always give me more of a very embed
when they gave me their money at one
time I did ten minutes for Russell
Peters and he gave me like two thousand
dollars of his own money and in cash and
I mean his brother gave it to me and
they were leaving and I ran I rather see
Clayton there's a big mistake I'm not
think you guys came to the DJ's money he
goes no that's your money are you sure
he goes cuz I'm gonna claim this now no
it was it was my money
and I ended up that day at the Hard Rock
Cafe I was there with Lisa and my wife
and her son Isaac and we're having a
pillow fight
okay you and Lisa are Isaac leave me
Isaac her son we're having a pillow
fight he's like six years old and then I
remember threw the pillow real hard and
I broke the hard rock cafe poster it was
like a Bob Dylan poster and it fell down
and they charged us almost $400 get out
of here that's what I said I said we
should just took this this frame took it
down the street for him it up for $20
put it back up or just put on the floor
and clean up the glass I try to argue
you know I mean I could fix this myself
I'll keep the post if you're gonna
charge me 400 bucks for the Charlie for
$10 he's what Ilia Lisa right right Mike
isn't Lisa the best yeah at least is
fantastic I learned a lot actually
working with Philippe and Lisa what have
you learned
she's a podcast producer what's up full
podcast and she's really on top of
everything from the social media to the
booking of the guests and to making sure
that the show runs smooth and yeah so
it's just been a real a real privilege
to work with those two yes yes she's
amber I didn't yeah do you know what Pat
periscope is ah I thought we could try
one but I want anniversary I know red
box I know all the things so what a book
let me ask you something Felipe now
amber is a friend of Sam so I don't need
to perceptibly no I'm just kidding Sam
Kinison
no Sam another daaa
bill bill okay now you were in rehab and
oh yeah a lot of stuff but how can you
stay off stuff but do so much weed I
don't know probably because I know that
with weed I'm gonna just calm down and
if I start drinking I don't know
something about drinking like as soon as
I get like some people get happy and
they start drinking and they wanna dream
or some people get happy and did you
want to leave right away could they feel
good me I get happy and I want to do
coke right away like as soon as I see
somebody I still like it it's targeting
buzz alright man who has the sniffles I
start looking for anybody that that's a
cold yeah that's what you're really
crack over there for crack and how I'll
be when you crack the first time 20 or
21 years old Wow yeah I got hook right
away like none of my friend will hooked
earlier than when they were like 13 14
years old
but I got hooked later on in life when I
was 20
Wow see what happened was people don't
know that when you get a touching you
Road hooked on crack it's not a good not
because our 20 year old got him hooked
it's not because 30 year old man I don't
hook it's because when you're selling
crack cocaine in say I'm 20 years old
and I'm studying crack cocaine out of my
house so there's no I don't I'm not
gonna trust no other 20 20 year old guy
to sell my crack because he's probably
that were older competitive so I'm a
higher a 17 year old guy a 17 year old
kid a 16 year old kid and he's gonna
sell the crack for me now you got a 15
year old kid selling crack who future
your kids don't know too many adults all
they know is another fifteen year old so
a 15 year old will sell crack to a 13
year old and a 13 year old we'll saw
crack to a channel road so that's how
you get 10 year olds getting hooked on
crack it's not because a 20 year old
sells crack it's because you got
teenagers that interact 10 year old
crack addicts I heard a story just today
that this guy was smoking crack at 6
years old with his mother
and he told her when he was six he was
like mom I don't think this is right and
she said you worry about you and I'll
worry about me yeah yeah yeah so what
was it like being a crack addict well
let me just say you gotta get help like
what were you doing um I was like um I
got into a lot of trouble growing up um
I got into his fight with some guy we
were fight well I got into a fight with
some guy
right after I finish watching some movie
I was on PCP and he was choking me to
death
oh my god and it was really choking me
and I don't know what else to do and I
bet half his ear off get out of here how
old were you I was like 20 years old
jail no and was it was like well I live
in a housing project so that we have our
own police for the housing police but
they were not there so like I live in a
neighborhood where nobody calls the cops
so that guy went to a hospital and he
didn't press charges he just said i'ma
kill you when I get at the hospital oh
my so that was scared because he didn't
think you were gonna rehab to not to not
get killed exactly yes movie I want to
stop doing crack place I was gonna hide
you knowledge on prior oh my god so when
you were hiding out to you did you get
better or you didn't care you were just
hiding out I got better but I didn't
want to stop but I just felt that I have
no one no corner you know I'm glad I did
stop because um I didn't want to fall
into that pattern like my brother or
other drug addicts they fall into a
pattern of um especially drug addicts
with no money like a rich person who
could as the money like an actor who has
the money to do drugs every day and
still live a normal life I wasn't that
person so I knew that if I don't if I
don't go to rehab imma die in the
streets see around my end of living in
the streets did you quit drinking then
when you were 20 add that that trip to
the rehab or did it yes I did I went ten
years
/ no no we didn't know alcohol and it
didn't happen - maybe like 2001 or 2002
I made you have to let sobriety in every
department they say I'm gonna do weed or
try it I don't know okay the first time
I did weed again was in 2003 I guess I
went ten years sober I was a dope
[ __ ] at the comic strip in El Paso
it's a comedy condo and I found out half
an ounce of marijuana inside a condo
there's some comedian saved for another
comedian and then the headliner went to
the smoke but he didn't know how to
write roll up joints I'm like hey so I
said alright I don't have a role it's
been a long time but I rolled up five
joints and I gave him three and I don't
know why I kept - nah
so another loan and the condo juice
you're a drug addict yes like a soldier
and Ivan and I was took weed with me
back home who takes we fill up a so
jolly and wider plane yeah put in my
pocket nobody say nothing in your pocket
and I got home and my girlfriend the
time she was surprised that I smoked
weed because she's more we but she never
did around me so now that I thought I
smoking in your way you're not like oh I
think I can start drinking again nothing
I'm not then not at the time and one day
I don't know why it happened it was in
Bakersfield California I think I took my
first no no no no no no no it was one
day I was at home and I was bored Friday
night nothing to do no gays nothing to
do and I'm watching The Big Lebowski and
I said you know what I never had a White
Russian I've never had a White Russian
in my life so I went - yeah they're good
I went to a browse in Silver Lake and I
went to I bought the white rice kind of
the Rousey love mix the white rugby
shirts super sugary like a milkshake
yes the White Russian club mix and the
mudslide
club mix and I went home and I made it
with ice
poured over eyes it felt good I got hot
I got real bud real hot right away yeah
then I said [ __ ] this I'm gonna have a
real drink and I went to the Red Lion
tavern and then from that moment I went
best rated home I got drunk and then as
I laid lower there little buddy Noah was
drinking I was like hiding in from the
past yeah oh you started drinking more
yeah and then in Bakersfield it was
enough that some DJ he offered me
cocaine and I took it and what happened
again to get you sober again oh man just
just smoking weed oh man I went from
that woman I did crack again in 2000
right there was that guy or 2003 I
spiraled down man like I went back to
smoking crack yes I mean really because
of one what right right because of the
big lebowski that one white russian-led
- yes I picked it you're right you're
right amber I did pick it up right away
how did you know I just pick it up right
away
because I I have seven years of sobriety
right I just picked it over away I went
to I should be actually I I did go back
to exactly the same so same scan is the
way of thinking I went straight to the
liquor store and I bought a pipe you
know about a crack pipe and it's funny
you never did that amber did you
I think I'd smoke crack accidentally
once okay I thought it was weed and then
I was like I don't think this is weak
yeah I saw it like it's funny like I
went straight to the to the hardware
section of the store and I bought a
heart and yes in the heart the hardware
section of the liquor store and I bought
a brillo pad a copper brillo pad and I
went to the front of the liquor store
and that brought about the crack pipe it
was there waiting for me with a little
rolled inside right next to the gum oh
you had another rehab stint while being
a stand-up
no no no no no rehab stint how did you
get off the second round I would working
with Gabriel s yes and I got too drunk
talking [ __ ] to him during the tour like
talking [ __ ] you fat-ass [ __ ] you you
ain't [ __ ] you know so he fired me and
he kicked me out of the gig this is
tough man like like this is the
headliner and ass
he's [ __ ] hooking me up with a job
instead I was like a brat we got cursed
you out yeah if you got drunk Fred and
was talking [ __ ] to me from San Jose we
had a stomach virus
I said stomach virus in Tempe and and IO
I hated a damn because it's all these
you'd hate you do sleep because it was
nothing but sports bars sports bars
shitty bar food and signs about guns
everything you can't bring a gun bring a
gun but but leave it there we like guns
in this bar you know I'm saying
with no carry guns you could hide your
gun and a gun in your hat right
yeah it was insane that was only no joke
oh my god but it's always every gig I've
done with you it feels like the same all
the same like we're in Orange County
I did a Brea Irvine I did to Irvine will
you I did some other place on the ten I
forgot what it's called
until her improv yes yes the same all
the st. the people look to saying and
I'm saying that not really character
those improv Spurs do Reno
I liked Reno cuz that that's a most
depressing town but it wasn't an improv
meaning it was it was a different kind
of theater kind of place but yeah we his
friend saw him out the guidance was
imprisoned as the MSNBC lockup comedy
man and we were eating at the shitty
casino the worst food and then we want
to leave so he's so he's eating that his
girlfriend didn't he took her plate he
sets and he's like because he's in
prison and used to once it you know if
everyone's plate remember that the
Birdman what's his story he's doing good
he's at home
uh-huh making his own oils those dabs
uh-huh is is that like doing the car
lack of pot when I did that it's lovably
it was crazy PCP of marijuana
I was so blitzed in my hotel room that I
was you know and whenever I'm blitzed I
always tell myself my mantra is no one
ever died from pot no one ever died from
that you know I because you know people
checked themselves in because they don't
know no one ever lost their mind knowing
you know you don't have to but I was
just telling myself worst case scenario
I knew I had to be at the airport in a
few hours to go home but I said worst
case scenario I pay for another night
here I thought if I'm like this I can't
go to the hotel I thought you'd be
holding me up and falling down and stuff
but it wore off
could you imagine Fred on crack Wow
please yeah getting doing crack with
Fred
seven year sober yeah yeah yeah not
anymore but not in a row yes and I'm
just a bad joke I know your drugs are so
bad I'm not eating and I am really smart
seven years and you did like pink
Martini's you said you did so crazy but
that's privileged it's it's vodka with
lime juice and white wine but I I didn't
know holic yeah I'm alike good yeah
definitely alcoholic I did coke a few
times the last time I ever drank I did a
bunch of coke and I just knew that I was
gonna keep doing it so I quit but I
always like I always fantasize about
smoking pot you know I I could take her
leave pot there were was phases where I
was pothead and I would smoke every day
and but then when I didn't do it I was
like yeah whatever
but sometimes now especially because
it's legal and there's all these like
fancy treats and lipgloss and like teas
and stuff I'm like oh man and I
fantasize about doing it but I'm not why
dispossess yeah why do you think but
it's cool you know I never smoked pot
not in seven years don't know nothing
and it's gotten better and less crazy
other meetings yeah yeah I'm pretty
active in the program on any or
hey did I ever tell you my 7 program
stories no ok then I'll tell you to make
a long story short and I probably won't
when I first moved to LA I was freaking
out and lonely and desperate and what do
you do and I don't know anyone so my
sister's husband my brother-in-law he's
really in a a and some people
proselytize it is that they're like it
saved me he's gonna save you they go you
better do the program you have all the
trade said I tell this story bring the
belt when it's getting rich are you a
friend of me but I think he was just
talking like the 12 steps oh no no he
said I said I don't drink he goes you
got all the symptoms of a drunk that's
wrong because you do think like an
alcoholic you really do thank you and
you should start drinking okay he goes
no this sister programs emotions
Anonymous there's something called
emotions Anonymous which I still don't
know what it is ei so he goes go to the
meetings and I had just seen that movie
with Michael Keaton and and I've talked
to you about this before I always wished
I was an alcoholic because they would
say man I got the program like my life
turned around I'm married I got a show
and everything so I always wish there
was something I could quit to you know
make my life better
alright I'm good at a program but I
never understood it was very vague it's
like hi I'm Steve I'm nervous and
depressed you know it's kind of like the
symptoms of drinking I don't know so so
there were a few funny things that
happened one time this woman raises a
hand she goes well I've been losing
weight and a guy who's applauding
clapping it's not [ __ ] good you
[ __ ] I've been sick and that's
humorous with you know okay all right
yeah we're gonna have a special guest
call again so so so then is he there
ignore me there Norm Macdonald we have
Felipe Esparza do you know hear me one
less Comic Standing few beers before you
we have
amber and Tozer what what's your middle
name
Lee Hey hi norm and what norm does is he
sets me up on the podcast he won't do so
this is payback like yeah he'll say did
Teddy go
he doesn't want to do juice Freddy and
then he likes to laugh and he said I
send them that link and never listens to
it so I was ready Freddy
yeah norm III did this this story
involves you and Felipe in a way I'm
connecting things well first of all I
was talking I've opened for him at the
improv in Tempe and in Brea and they all
feel like this depressing mall it's like
a Chucky Cheese it's like an Orange
County there's no character I know yeah
yeah a guy in on Saturday I did so bad
on Friday they're brought in like the
regional manager that like that's
reimbursing muscular guy okay wait they
brought it and wait another comic or
another manager Oh manager like it's
like your ass and like their Chuckie
Cheese the bunny he was a large big
tough guy like that like Clark so that
I'd be funny the next yes I had that I
did um I forgot this place God it was
San Antonio in the first place I ran
into anti-semitism they were booing me
go hey mr. Choo where'd you get you know
his job you know I never ran into
anything and I remember that I did this
morning radio no one ever came to his
show because I did morning radio and it
was a country-western radio like I don't
know much about country-western I know
the gamble broke people don't like going
to a show
16 hours after they listen to the radio
they never remember I did your friend
what's his name Tim Conway Junior's
radio show going this is big radio
hunting
Beach and I go because I did a Barnes
and Noble in Huntington Beach I'm on the
thing the only person that came to the
book signing was Keith Reznor and tennis
is going on Tim Conley jr. mentioning
over enough Fred will be at hunter did
you know Keith Reznor is reasoner yeah
I'm a feeler
he has he I'm so stood in his podcast
too
this is a guy amber and a Felipe he goes
to me come to my show he goes uh you
know I have Asperger's I go what's that
mean because I have no empathy at all
and his frankly that's right I hurt my
ankle he didn't care you guys my friends
hurt I may be the last face you ever see
because I said isn't that everywhere
every comedian has no empathy that he
goes I don't care about other people and
at all
I told Filipe he loves the story that
you like norm where when I was working
in New York people would try to sell
Rodney jokes he'd come over what do you
got I don't know you know what the [ __ ]
is this alright let me look at this
sheet you know I put its glasses on and
you write up all these jokes so remember
use doing a lot of NBC specials so I
give too much discretion to the other no
III guess I teach one of liberties I
take too many liberties and he also
Eddie Murphy he came into the comic
strip in Fort Lauderdale he was doing
another gig right before Murphy got sad
Night Live so Murphy you said the other
thing hey scream at the end worried
everyone do it get it out of your system
and he goes to Murphy I hate to say the
word cuz you're gonna go no way with
that inner [ __ ] you know and Murphy was
crushed you know that rowdy is gonna way
you're gonna go with that [ __ ]
so so one time I remember that rodney
proceeded
Eddie Murphy no no no I was doing in
1982 Fort Lauderdale comic strip with
Eddie Murphy Rob Bartlett think one
other guy Mike Reynolds it was like a
gambler and yes yes and it's funny how I
I'm going yes he tried doing like a what
was that guy that do practical jokes I
tried doing a one where he's in debt and
and he's going [ __ ] you I'm not gonna
pay my but I owe you taunted people he
owes money to so he said you sense that
jimmy kimmel who does pranks and Jerry
goes well this is you're a deadbeat
you're not paying people back who cares
about this psychotic people who all he
owes money so he thought it's gonna be
there and this guy Bruce Fein produced
it this guy who merch so then he showed
me like he had a t-shirt that had was
for Shaun Wyatt I know just all these
Wayans brothers movies probably you've
been in every one of Hollywood and
caricature when you said they brought in
the manager when I did on this place I
forgot it I forgot what it's called in
my Tempe I've been a lot of Arizona
those San Antonio so what happened was
these people like all your stories are
for one thing and you know how when
people it's worse when when people
heckle you guys shut up and they applaud
but you have ever when they talking and
only you hear them talk so I said could
you tell the man I said today yeah
bouncer could you tell him if they don't
shut up they're kicked out he
interpreted that as kicked him out so he
said get out so there's one woman on
crutches so it looked like I kicked out
a crippled woman and she's hobbling
across her crutches and they're booing
me so so then they're going hey and I
said if you keep booing I can't do my
act so I shut them up and they they was
sitting there with their arms folded and
I walked off so they were gonna fire me
so the manager had a meeting he
goes hack we prevent this from happening
again I gots an isolated incident he
goes I have an idea don't do those
thrill-seeker jokes because you're
antagonizing them I'm a badass I drank
milk that expired yesterday because when
you do that you're making you're making
them be aggressive because you're saying
you know don't you're challenging them
so norm I am I did a gig went to the
south and it was they said listen do you
mind this guy goes on before you his
name was James Gregory that guy he's not
the amber good guy no okay
he is so he's introduced as the funniest
man in the world ha ha ha but he tells
him to say that yeah yeah that's what
his fing says so then I'm reading one I
look down at the menu and it's like the
James Gregory burger the James Gregory
and all I hear is like insane laughs
turns out the guy is the funniest guy in
the world
Wow and everyone loves and then I have
to go on and so he's in the south
I know how he missed out on that tour
but you know in the South they have
their own circus and people the
Christian comics are different like
they're kind of fat and loud you know
like Ralphie May I think yeah yeah yeah
but not as smart as Ralph you man right
right
but but real real tough and loud and
then I grew up with you know and I'd
have the Jay Leno acid on with the
skinny ties everyone was a [ __ ] whoo
that's Jerry here vase this mail now
what's that
everything about today there's a man
who's a [ __ ] no it's a man who's born a
man but identifies as a man so you would
be a sis male
well he was just now I did that
understand he's you know there's trans
and then there's this it it's a it's a
word that's made to like marginalized oh
no I didn't name the main market of
people you know I've been so that you
two are like some freak you know that
you're born male and then crazily enough
you identify a office Oh nothin broadly
thing is so I went up to Rodney I
thought I had this great idea not for
Zack remember you had these NBC specials
where he did sketches and I said Rodney
alright this is a running gag where
first you're dressed as a cop you're in
a homicide division you hey I got no
suspects no suspects at all and then and
then and then he's looking at me like
what the [ __ ] you talking about go wait
wait wait and then then you work at a
drug store you I got no sucrets no
sucrets at all and then you work at a
toy store I got no pup beds what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about
and I go I go I have no use for it I
thought you could have it because I got
no use for that [ __ ] either you look at
Mexico got no Chiclets Chiclets I got no
I got no Rockets a I'm working at Radio
City like when I was on update Lauren we
just put people on updates and wanted to
be on the show and no use for them but
it was Rodney's birthday so Laura goes
but Rodney on updates like how can we
put them on like I'm here to just put
them on and say here's Rodney doing this
joke but what else could he do you know
so then the guy who the main writer on
the show Jim Downey is kind of a genius
he had this idea so he pitched it to
Rodney you know I was on the other line
and he goes you know that thing would be
funny if you went on and norm said like
you know you're 75 now he's no housewife
I get no respect to these talk and then
norm goes well I can't believe that you
know a man of your stature you know
certainly a good respect for his
children yeah no you're kidding you know
I do some kids Joe well I find that very
hard to believe Rodney what about your
baby certainly
respect of all people you know I'd say
you know respect for him so writing down
he goes
you know Rodney has no use for writers
do you think it was just guys your hand
you know you had $5 to go outside the
[ __ ] nightclub you know somewhere I
have a story that involves sort of you
and Phillippi in a way Philippe Philippe
I when I opened for him in Brea his wife
told me this is I forgot this service
but you probably have a lot of checks
waiting for you because when they put
your stuff on albums on um what's it
called uh well you remember in the old
days he'd go to the improv and there'd
be 450 checks to Jerry sign so yeah
aye-aye-aye
yeah now with the Laugh Factory I hardly
do it but there was a show I did and
then I I waited to the next time to get
the check was six months later and they
go oh no Jamie rips up the check if you
know if you don't do seven six months I
see him wait and don't have feedback you
know he's he's ripping up the check it's
I I don't want to name names but a
friend of mine I've known for 30 years
has a podcast and Jamie's his manager
and I thought you know my paper backs
out try to go in podcast and he goes I'm
sorry Freddy Jamie says you don't have
enough Twitter followers to be on his
podcast so Who am I more mad at I'm I'm
a mad that and like a remember I'm
trying not to say the word amber doesn't
like I look I go on the thing to see
other people he said on his podcast I
have more than him but yes so it's like
I just did Marc Maron get the President
on and generally don't have enough clear
their followers and he goes look Freddy
we just had someone he had a hundred
thousand Twitter followers like it's a
podcast you know I mean it's like one
thing though I can't get you in my movie
I can't get you through to be my TV show
as a writer it's not up to me it's up to
hell for
but you know this is a podcast it's
Thanksgiving or Christmas oh yeah
jamie has these things you know where he
does good good well deeds but he's
always has an agenda like when I read on
Seinfeld he put a sign up yeah he goes
watch Freddie's episode on Seinfeld you
know he put a sign up and and and and
people go what do you mean Freddie's
episode he goes did you tell Jenni tell
Jenni you know so it's je ddy tell Jenni
so one time he had the cameras there and
he's doing a you know Thanksgiving he's
feeding homeless people and at the
latter fact it never really homeless
people it just kind of you know comics
they don't really bus in like it so so
so Jen quick like Steven Alan green or
someone you know comedian yes so they'd
have so they'd have comedians dishing
out the food right so Jen cameras
dishing out food here's like that lady
was that lady they're not the comedian
like a thousand years ago with science
elves and those people what do you mean
a lady Lane burglar Elaine Boosler oh
yeah people like that dish at the food
so there's two Janice dishing Africa no
no put J more there for the camera good
deed but he she got bumped so norm
Philippe told me about this thing where
you declare if you uh if any if any
comedy bits have you've done have been
on these are not podcast what does it
call Pandora and it may be checks
waiting for you a played on satellite
yes
so he says fill out all the forms so I
see he and and he goes well I'll tell
you what happened is that I so you
declare what albums you've been on
comedy and there's a check waiting for
you so I said oh I was on this thing
called the fantastic forward nor
McDonald and they said okay we're fine
we're filing an injunction against our
McDonald we're doing a call I could what
are you talking about they go
okay well this is a union where because
other credit it just says nor McDonald's
and they go no one of the guys so you're
entitled to a fourth of it you could you
I did that but I couldn't know and I
called you up I didn't let the message
go it seems like I'm suing you like
where we're filing a report against or
McDonald and so Norman
yeah no no if you're a performer on
these things they say there's a two
thousand this two thousand dollars
waiting for you nor for the normal but
if but if I filed my phone I get five
hundred but then I have to tell them no
sound something sound soundbite like you
all a [ __ ] you've done from your albums
yes you you have thousands of dollars
waiting for you right Philippe yes I'm
the I got a call one time and they said
I'm you have money waiting for you
because I did a comedy album with some
guy named true all out of XM radio a
long time ago in DC and then I fill out
those paper words and I get checks now
every month every time I comedy is
played in a radio guys like Gary Gulman
Hollywood soundbite guys like Gary
Gulman said oh I didn't declare and it
gets thirty thousand if you you put your
albums and they played on it we're
looking it up or ask Lisa but they get
all these checks because if your albums
has played on satellite or serious or
all uh so that I did my declaration you
know how much I got thirty dollars
because the song I did was on handy
manny like we work together
thirty dollars story like I don't have
any comedy albums out the only thing I
did that's played is the Fantastic Four
so so this is the secret snap oh it's
not played on anything so so Felipe do
you know the Fantastic Four
yes so this is funny norm someone sent
me the thing I forgot years ago we did a
sketch where on his album ridiculous oh
I'm plugging this dorm if you have
anything to plug and I'm just kidding
someone will say due to your podcast
it's because people say I don't want to
be too arrogant oh this is people say do
my thing it's fifty miles away
it's a my house you could
a book like that they make it oh wow
like I'm doing you a favor and so so
basically so there was a bid where he's
mr. Dahlin exchange sound exchange
didn't have someone fill it out there's
thousands of dollars waiting for you and
his own exchange all the thing I read
bit you've done in everything so in this
2004 the Fantastic Four alone bit okay
so the Fantastic Four normal a clip is
no that'll be on the the website well
before the clip on the way and norm you
could plug anything we'll put a clip on
the web so I'm just kidding when people
say that so okay this is the bit risk
all sound exchange and what they do is
it's a free it's a free Union and they
make no money but what they do is I'm
they find every comedy bit that you ever
recorded that's an audio and they they
find it on every radio station every
compilation the sea hand or I accept
Radio Pandora and they get it all
together and they send your checks so
I'm you got a lot of money coming to you
thank you yes oh nice Jesus it's like a
lot of paperwork to fill out but once
you fill it out
it pays off yeah and I've so I can I
file the injunction against here that I
was wanted a fantastic for because I
wanted it just as used the performer I
gotta say so so amber I gotta include
amber amber amber is great
say hi to Norma your fan of norms yeah
you we invited you we did a bit with
Fred the great Fred Willard we acted out
in the war scene and if you ever want to
be in one of those but okay so the bit
was Felipe in amber that he will this is
how they got their names and he's saying
your names the thing your the torch
because you're a torture invisible I
could stretch so I'm mister fantastic
and they going wait a minute why are you
called mister fantastic so so that's how
I live so I Here I am I was like very
nervous eyes Johnny the storm Johnny
Blaze so I kept saying I'd argue but
then go right thing like their backup
thing I kept it I was so nervous I
needed a thing to validate remember that
yeah
what the thing out of name Ben Grimm I
go well then then why isn't this true
what I'm saying because I think at one
time we were doing rehearsal and norm
wanted to the great Steve Higgins to
talk more than me because he's better at
improv he goes remember the thing is to
leader so I kept saying well look I have
a point to make now Ben is it correct
and so I'm so yeah so who was some of
the judges you had Felipe when you did
last Comic Standing Natasha Natasha
Leggero and the click handler and the
late great road oh wow yes greg Giraldo
pretty young well Andy Kindler
I remember Jan Caron was auditioning the
preliminaries and he go he'd go awkward
you know cuz he knew Jan param and like
he did like Paula Lynn I guess and I
really strange part is that the judges
know the performers what you think would
invalidate the whole the whole well I
remember there was one where it kind of
like a game show scandal of 50 well
caught they did one with Colin Quinn at
the time he had that show tough crowd
and Jim Norton was a regular on it and
then he was auditioning for for Colin
Quinn and then he passed and you see
Colin laughing at his jokes like who is
this no guy he's great you know Jim
Norton was on tough I'm on him when
Colin was a judge on Last Comic Standing
12 growed yes but he was already a
regular in tough crowd so you see Jim
Norton doing his set and Colin laughing
I caused this youngster he's he's I got
a kick out of him who's this guy he's
pretty edgy he's going some way yes yes
well it's weird because I don't want to
name names but one
guy that was kind of vilified on your
season opened for one of the judges and
blew them away so he thought maybe the
person had hostility towards him who the
judges the judges was norm it was the
norm Keenen Ivory Wayans or Roseanne now
you you
he was Amber watching Last Comic
Standing for more is gonna feel forced
being like do you know what this is like
norm I've had a few times where I've
pitch shows and it was a nightmare and I
wanted this show to be past because I
because I didn't want to be involved
with the people pit you know who were
called a quarter of my team but you know
it's like did you ever pitch something
you have three executives and you're
talking but you got to give eye contact
with each one the show hey this is Lois
Shecky the assistant but he's he's
important too so okay I'm it's like
curve meets dinner for five and then you
turn your head to this guy in amber I
think you'd really like this you know
talking about no I'm guys they're
perfect of that Fred wolf is perfect of
that oh yeah don't get a kick out of it
when okay yeah I'm a burger okay amber
that's a very comedian norm comedian I
see the reformed def jam but then I read
that you know he's very perfect and I
said damn I had a heart attack though
you're a comedian I had a heart attack
lastly when I found out that was your
favorite comic oh yeah no cuz I saw him
on Def Jam but I think it was because it
was so hilarious because everyone was
trying taught and the sack amount with a
cowboy yeah
yes like one here's to gimmicks instead
of what he has a cowboy hat and he says
hammer yeah had a big-ass hamburger he
does it Chuck yes hamburger yeah no I've
seen that guy yeah he ducky quack quack
there's this thing Norman I came across
many years ago before Oh Jay was in
prison for the second thing he did a
Punk'd kind of made no sense where he
was doing practical jokes like a punk
show but he's scaring the [ __ ] out of
people like one he's recording us grab
CD cuz you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm doing the
guys like shivering and he's like
delivering pizza and he goes I'm gonna
beat you up and so not only does OJ
prank characters he did like an old
Jewish guy with a yarmulke big nose like
a butt a wart on it doing a rap song at
the end of the things you've been choose
the Minnesota and women with no shirts
dancing for no reason yeah the
interstitials were all like I I did this
thing where okay where we were hosting a
strip poker tournament and I'm in as
some hedonist hedonist resort in Jamaica
and I thought Oh naked ladies everyway
hedonism I didn't know it was the
stupidest gig where and then they go so
that National Lampoon which is not like
the old days they they said we want you
to come in for writers meeting it turned
out all it was was they were trying to
sell the show to some investors these
guys some who owned Denny's in Arizona
it's always Arizona so so I was part of
the pitch and Fred Stoller you've seen
him on friends and kato kaelin is here
like oh my god so so basically it was
these the women were not attractive they
had um you know middle-aged kind of
heavy women trying to let loose from the
Midwest you know playing naked
volleyball but they had the nude side
the fruit side and so the the good the
food was on the newt side and I and I
wanted to get the chicken so they had
this Jamaican lady in a security
governor's you have to take your clothes
off if you come here I won no not it's a
right and so all right not a good story
normally think plug all right hey norm
thanks a lot for well he first thought
about he's now amber would find him
charming because he they're like oh just
teasing her yeah he'll like norm once
did something taunting me where he said
let's meet at Jan's restaurants or
someplace or the silver spoon and went
alright so then he knew I couldn't stand
Kate on his shoes up it's a wonderful
morning and he's dancing on tables and
putting his arm around people you
[ __ ] [ __ ] he does this contrived
fake charming guy those fake thing so he
the first did so they had all these
models these women that one of them were
going you know I'm a hooker but this is
good for exposure I'm hoping this Albany
break into acting where they start the
thing it was in it was in nude women
women playing poker and and they take
their clothes off as they lose but they
started off with the naked women his
Melissa and she's walking down waving
naked like where's the suspense why do I
care so kato is doing these hit the
special bits of the so one of them took
a lot of diet pills and starved herself
to to get ready for this big break so so
so that they're doing the what's a call
the the teaching us how to play poker
and it's all these you know women with
big breasts breast implants and me and
Kato so then a woman had a seizure she's
having a like you know and I what do you
do and I they said put something in our
mouth and I took chopsticks and and then
they had to call the paramedic so so it
was a real hairy seenin and Cato's
behind like making faces and jumping up
and down like mugging when this woman's
having a seizure
oh and he's gonna be like Kramer he's
gonna sue me
and alright I made that up about Kato
wink wink and and then and then from
okay kid you get sued from a third hand
story so that the only the the
prostituted the models would share rooms
and once said you know Keita would knock
on the door go room service and come in
and jump in bed with them and she goes I
don't think it's sexual harassment cuz
he's making jokes it doesn't count this
sexual harassment if you're joking
around and so that was a big break now
okay norm I have a confession you know
story your toes because what guys try to
be funny
generally it's not the comedian's it's
the serious actors and I was on this
celebrity baseball softball team with
Fred Willard and already my hand but
then there were actors you know so the
actors always try to be funny like the
comedians were just trying to seriously
play ball you know anyways we were
playing as there's this guy Michael Bay
who was a soap opera actor like super
handsome and at the time was dating
JFK's he wrote a book about dating JFK's
go wife you know that's not that's what
he was famous for so he was very
handsome guy know from his um Baywatch
and he was on soap operas but anyways
we're playing the Jacksonville Jaguars
and they told us you can't slide you
know you're not allowed to slide because
just in case we hit one of the Jaguars
ankles and broke it or something so so
we're told not to slide so Artie Artie
Lange hits a she's a really good
baseball player and he hits a triple off
the wall and he runs around second base
he's running to third and he goes to
slide and he remembers at the last
second not the slide so he tries to stop
himself from sliding and he snaps his
ankle breaks on his hand he's writhing
and screaming and Michael Bay is playing
second base runs over starts [ __ ] him
in the air
okay this is the end of part 1 of this
great Colin with noir McDowell Felipe
Esparza amber we're going to put part 2
on next Friday continue this hysterical
phone call with noir McDonald please
subscribe to this podcast on iTunes give
it a good rating give it a review this
this really helps please join my
facebook page for updates about stuff
follow us on twitter i'm fred underscore
Stoller funny felipe amber Tozer so man
we had so much fun with this so we'll
see you next week thank you
you